- [Instructor] We are
told that Shui concluded
the quadrilaterals, these two over here,
have four pairs of congruent
corresponding angles.
We can see these right over there.
And so, based on that she concludes
that the figures are similar.
What error if any, did Shui
make in her conclusion?
Pause this video and try to
figure this out on your own.
All right, so let's just remind ourselves
one definition of similarity
that we often use on geometry class,
and that's two figures are similar
is if you can through a series of
rigid transformations and dilations,
if you can map one figure onto the other.
Now, when I look at these two figures,
you could try to do something.
You could say okay, let me shift it
so that K gets mapped onto H.
And if you did that,
it looks like L would get mapped onto G.
But these sides KN and LM right over here,
they seem a good bit longer.
So, and then if you try to dilate it down
so that the length of KN is
the same as the length of HI
well then the lengths of KL
and GH would be different.
So it doesn't seem like you could do this.
So it is strange that Shui
concluded that they are similar.
So let's find the mistake.
I'm already, I'll already rule out C,
that it's a correct conclusion
'cause I don't think they are similar.
So let's see.
Is the error that a rigid
transformation, a translation
would map HG onto KL?
Yep, we just talked about that.
HG can be mapped onto KL
so the quadrilaterals are
congruent, not similar.
Oh, choice A is making an
even stronger statement
because anything that is
congruent is going to be similar.
You actually can't have
something that's congruent
and not similar.
And so, choice A does not make any sense.
So our deductive reasoning
tells us it's probably choice B.
But let's just read it.
It's impossible to map quadrilateral GHIJ
onto quadrilateral LKNM using only
rigid transformations and dilations
so the figures are not similar.
Yeah, that's right.
You could try, you could map HG onto KL,
but then segment IJ would
look something like this,
IJ would go right over here.
And then, if you tried to dilate it,
so that the length of HI
and GJ matched KN or LM,
then you're gonna make HG bigger as well.
So, you're never gonna be able
to map them onto each other
even if you can use dilations.
So I like choice B.